megan the
stallion not megan the stallion there's
two e's
she's proper that's english proper
stunning okay you're familiar with this
girl
uh a little bit all i know is that her
song
savage
is everywhere i'm a savage
fuji hood and ratchet
what are those the words nasty boujee
nasty something like that yeah that's
gotta be something else i just hear
vanessa go nasty
i'm a savage and anyway she's talking
you know i gotta look it up now you're
gonna you're gonna look it up
sing it if you're gonna look it up i'll
say you have to sing all right i'll sing
it don't me okay all right
so mega the stallion uh talks on i heart
uh media i heart radio and she talks
about the importance of financial
literacy and her
relationship with bitcoin to transition
back to bitcoin so she said she learned
the importance of financial literacy at
a young age the hot girl ceo
she's 26 she's she's cash app's newest
spokesperson and she wants to help her
fans understand the world of finances
particularly
crypto particularly bitcoin she says
quote unquote after
i downloaded the app cache app this is
not a commercial for cash app she said i
got some bitcoin right it was really a
simple experience because especially
because cash app lets you buy fractions
of stock or cryptocurrency i wanted to
dip my toe in
and make sure i educated myself on the
process so this is what i was talking
about you don't need to go all in on
bitcoin that's coming from like a
millionaire making these sounds she's
like i'm not going really recent
millionaire recent she no one heard of
megan destalia before the pandemic sure
right at least i didn't so she dipped
her toe and she didn't go all in okay
uh she says i was able to pay off my
student loan and this was a huge moment
for me
a huge moment for anyone she said and i
realized how important financial
literacy is you have to take the time to
learn and educate yourself on the
process but once you do you can have a
lot of fun true that megan
the
stallion and look she's not wrong
pay off your debt
save that money start to invest
and then you can start to diversify me
i'm a big stock market guy invest in
reits right etfs index funds little
crypto maybe a board ape nft you never
know what's going to happen out there so
megan the stallion shout out to her
being a savage inside
and outside of the studio you want to
sing her song real quick on that note
yeah so it goes
i'm a savage it's classy bougie ratchet
yeah
that's it sassy moody
nasty
acting stupid what's happening
what is happening right now david
what is happening right now
so uh you know what a little little
quick shout out to david well oh yeah
great job david thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you
but shout out to megan when we went to
rolling loud
yeah and we filmed you know people if
you're not familiar i do a lot of man on
the street stuff we actually have an
awesome
911 remembrance man on the street coming
out that's going to be on the main
channel coming out tomorrow vanessa's
chopping that up she kills those things
she's become like the go-to editor for
that kind of stuff but anyway it's going
to be awesome
we do a lot of management we went to
rolling loud and who are the people the
most excited to see out of every rapper
that was there megan the
stallion want to know why one and only
why because she's a savage classy
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broke